at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half-mile before my hands start
shaking the episode is brought to you by
wealthfront and this is a very unique
sponsor wealthfront is a massively
disruptive
in a good way set it and forget it
investing service led by technologists
from places like Apple and world-famous
investors it has exploded in popularity
in the last two years and they now have
more than two and a half billion dollars
under management in fact some of my very
good friends investors in Silicon Valley
have millions of their own money in
wealth front so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that in a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront dot-com forward
slash tim take the risk assessment quiz
which only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free
exactly the portfolio they put you in
and if you just want to take their
advice run with it do it yourself you
can do that or as I would you can set it
and forget it and here's why the value
of wealth front is in the automation of
habits and strategies that investors
should be using on a regular basis but
normally aren't great investing is a
marathon not a sprint and little things
that you may or may not be familiar with
like automatic tax loss harvesting
rebalancing your portfolio across more
than 10 asset classes and dividend
reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of
time wealth front as I mentioned since
it's using software instead of retail
locations etc can offer all of this at
low costs that were previously
completely impossible right off the bat
you never pay commissions or account
fees for everything they charge 0.25
percent per year on assets above the
first 15,000 which is managed for free
if you use my link wealthfront com
forward slash Tim that is less than five
dollars a month to invest a thirty
thousand dollar account for instance now
normally when I have a sponsor on the
show is because I use
them and recommend them in this case
it's a little different I don't use
wealthfront yet because I'm not allowed
to here's the deal they wanted to
sponsor this podcast but because of SEC
regulations companies that invest your
money are not allowed to use client
testimonials so I couldn't be a user and
have them on the podcast but I've been
so impressed by wealthfront that I've
invested a significant amount of my own
money at least for me in the team and
the company itself so I am an investor
and hope to soon use it as a client now
back to the recommendation as a Tim
Ferriss show listener you'll get $15,000
managed for free if you decide to open
an account but just start with seeing
the portfolio that they would suggest
for you take two minutes fill out their
questionnaire at wealthfront com forward
slash Tim it's fast it's free there's no
downside that I can think of this
episode is brought to you by fresh books
fresh books is used by a ton of the
startups that I work with or advise many
of the fastest growing it is used by
almost all of the contractors that I
work with it is the easiest way online
to send invoices get paid track your
time for invoicing track your clients so
they get to the point of paying you all
that stuff that you could possibly find
and right now you can get a free month
of complete unrestricted use and you do
not need a credit card for the trial to
claim your free month just go to fresh
ebooks.com forward slash tim and enter
tim in the how did you hear about us
section you can of course customize it
to fit your brand with your own logo in
color and fresh books shows you whether
or not for instance a client has looked
at the invoice they can send late
payment reminders to your clients
automatically so you do not have to
think about it or chase them down and
you can track your hours you can do all
sorts of things there our mobile app
lets you take pictures of your receipts
and freshbooks will organize them for
you later
it is a great piece of software and if
you are in a small business or maybe a
fast growing business that is feeling
growing pains and you need to streamline
then this is a place to look because
certainly for me this has been a
headache in the past and it doesn't have
to be a headache for you so check out
FreshBooks dot-com forward slash tim and
try it out and see what you think
hello guten tag konbanwa and I'm a
second hello for listening I have many
things to share this is Tim Ferriss and
welcome to another episode of the Tim
Ferriss show where it is my job to
deconstruct world class performers to
tease out the habits routines learnings
favorite books etc that you can use and
test in your own life and this episode
features not an athlete not a politician
but a strategist a young fellow I've
known for quite a long time Ryan holiday
and he can be found at Ryan holiday that
is at Ryan holiday on the Twitter's and
other social I was going to call this
episode useful lessons from workaholics
anonymous corporate implosions and more
or alternative title Howard Hughes
versus Elon Musk
but in all it reminded me of a movie
that I saw recently featuring Sandra
Bullock called I believe it was our
brand is crisis Ryan has survived and
thrived in some case suffered in more
crisis management situations than just
about anyone his age I think at least on
a national stage he is of course as I
mentioned the strategist and writer he
dropped out of college at 19 to
apprentice under Robert Greene author of
the 48 laws of power and later served at
I believe age 21 or so as director of
marketing for American Apparel his
current company brass check has advised
clients like Google taser and complex as
well as many prominent best-selling
authors Ryan himself has written four
books most recently the obstacle is the
way and actually his brand new book is
ego is the enemy but the obstacle is the
way was translated into 17 languages and
developed a cult following among NFL
coaches all sorts of world-class
athletes TV personalities political
leaders and others around the world he
lives in a tiny ranch outside Austin
Texas with his miniature donkeys and a
whole collection of random animals and
his wife and so on not saying his wife
is an animal although we're all animals
so that's okay Ryan and I cover a lot in
this conversation including meltdowns
that he has gone through since he last
was on the podcast how he handles them
workaholics and
how it works what worked for him what
didn't the tipping points for his last
book before egos the enemy the obstacles
away why did he become such a cult
classic and make its way into the
Seahawks and the Patriots and everywhere
else how did that happen we talked about
it
external versus internal obstacles a
Sherman versus grant style leadership
and success in quotation marks Howard
Hughes versus Elon Musk thinking and
acting on first principles and much more
so please say hi to Ryan when you have a
chance on Twitter at Ryan holiday and I
hope you enjoy this conversation as much
as I did thanks for listening Ryan good
to be chatting yeah it's good to be
talking it has been a little while since
we've done this in the public forum and
I think about you every morning and
there's a very specific reason for that
I went to a hotel recently on the East
Coast and it turns out they provide
quotes to people who are checking in so
they'll leave a quote on the bedside
table or something like that and the
quote that was on the bedside table I
kept with me and actually taped it to my
refrigerator which is you may recognize
this when jarred unavoidably by
circumstance revert it once to yourself
and don't lose the rhythm more than you
can help I think I just lost them lost
over to them in there a little bit
you'll have a better grasp of harmony if
you keep going back to it and of course
that's Marcus Aurelius it's one of my
favorites it is a spectacular quote and
it makes me think of your tattoos and
I'm not sure everyone listening is
familiar with your tattoo is probably
not so is it relates to those with
Maxim's what do you have written on your
body so I just I just have two and it's
gonna seem somewhat self-indulgent but
I'll say the tattoos came first and the
books came second right so I have the
the obstacle is the way tattooed on my
left forearm which was the title of the
the first book that you and I did
together and that's a that's a
derivation of a Marcus Aurelius quote
this idea of the impediment to action
advance his action what stands in the
way becomes the way
and then there's the Zen saying you know
the obstacle is the path and then in
late 2014 I did I got the ego is there
it just says ego is the enemy there's no
thought but ego is the enemy which is
then became the title of the book but to
me I think in almost every situation
those two reminders either help calm you
down prevent you from doing something
stupid or boneheaded or sort of give you
I would say like some sort of dose of
the obstacles away from me it gives me
some sort of optimism that it doesn't
really matter what's going on or how bad
it is I can get through it and I you
know I look at those when I wake up I
look I love looking at them when I go
swimming when I go running I you know I
see them every day and they remind me of
those two really important ideas and I I
guess I haven't haven't developed the
stomach for the ink just yet on the skin
so I'm settling for the refrigerator but
I was I'm glad you clarified that the
that the tattoos came first and the
books came second because otherwise I
was thinking to myself it'd be it's
gonna be great when you have kids and
start writing children's books like with
the tattoos that you'll end up on your
body well it's it's like you know I
wrote a book on growth hacking that I'm
not gonna put that on to put that on my
body you're not gonna get it like a
[ __ ] stamp with growth hacking on it so
the sorry guys have had a lot of tea
today but the the the very beginning of
egos the enemy opens up with you
witnessing and in a way being involved
with the very public implosion of
American Apparel right and then having
in effect a meltdown of your own can you
talk about that and how stoicism figured
into that or didn't like when the rubber
hit the road I mean I'd just love to
hear you explain the circumstances for
people yeah yeah and it's a it's a
somewhat tough situation because as you
know anytime there's millions of dollars
involved there's certain confidentiality
agreements and things like that and I
mean so I mean
the the short of it is in 2014
Jeff Charney who was my mentor he was a
close friend of mine was fired by the
board of directors at American Apparel
and he he did not take that news well as
I imagined most people would not and it
turned into a hostile takeover it was a
very contentious time and and I'd been
called in as a consultant to help with
the turnaround of the company and I by
the board by the port so it you know
immediately that put me at odds with
someone who I'd been close to for a very
long time and looked up to and and and
admired but at the same time I I was
able to see the situation a bit more
objectively than than he was so I you
know I I didn't view it as a betrayal
i-i've sort of viewed it as a as a
commitment to the company to which I had
worked for a very long time and and done
a lot of work that I was proud of and
and and had a lot of friends and
colleagues and there was great people
there and so you know I just finished
the the obstacles the way it just come
out I was at the end of you know how it
is after you you put out a book you go
on book tour and you're just looking
forward to the day where that all ends
two days after it ended is when I got
the call and so and so I know and so
that you know I immediately found myself
back living in Los Angeles well my my
future wife was in Austin and you know
I'm living in an air B&B I'm working
constantly I've got another book that I
have to fit I basically completely over
committed myself to what became a total
chaotic nightmare of conflict and
intrigue and backstabbing and you know
all the stuff that one would imagine
would be going on in a in a hostile
takeover of a company where the founder
had been unceremoniously ejected and I I
I don't want to say I had a nervous
breakdown
but I
I very clearly realized not soon enough
I realized that I'd I've always had my
life been able to take on more and more
stuff like every time an opportunity
comes up I've been able to jump on it
and I never felt like okay that's
overreaching right this is when I
finally hit that wall and my
relationship hit that wall my sort of
personal happiness hit that wall you
know I was as tense as a human being
could possibly be I wasn't sleeping you
know that threats are being through it
so it was just it was just one of the
worst periods of my life and you know it
forced not only was I dealing with you
know watching someone I looked up to
behave in these ways that I didn't agree
with and and looking at the consequences
of some of his behavior and being forced
to say you know is that is that what I
want to be like is this the right thing
to do and then also having to look at
you know this idea of like why do I keep
you know unthinkingly plunging myself
into situations because I can't say no
to money I can't say no to you know the
the thrill of a chaotic situation you
know I I can't say hey that's that's a
great opportunity but it's not for me
and so it just you know I I hit this
complete wall and I eventually ended up
you know walk walking away you know
amicably from from the board when they
decided to go in in a different
direction before ultimately going back
in the other direction and and I went
near the directions that they were
thinking about going so so they you know
they reconsidered bringing him back on
and then they decided against it and
then then ultimately the company was was
forced to declare bankruptcy and and is
now privately held and and you know this
was it was a it was a the company was in
very dire straits and the the conflict
was ultimately I don't want to say fatal
but it but it put it on life support
from which it's not clear that it will
recover and I mean I hope it does but
you know dove walked away with nothing
employees like my
elf who had you know had stock options
and and and had bought shares in the
company we lost everything the board
lost their shares so it was it was a the
definition of what became a lose-lose
situation and which you know I talked a
little bit about in the book this idea
of when bad stuff happens ego is what
makes us make it worse because we can't
step away and ironically dove has now
started his own company and it's it's
interesting to think what but how
different things would have been if he'd
done that in 2014 but it was it was a
you know I what I took away from it
ultimately when I when I finally got
back to my actual life it was like you
know I carved out a career for myself
which was as a writer which very few
people can do which I'd always wanted to
do which is what makes me happy and then
you know some someone dangled something
shiny over here and I jumped into it
unthinkingly and and you know very in a
very real way risked all of it
because I wasn't able to really decide
what was important to me and what
mattered you know and and I think I
think a lot of people find themselves in
situations like that where you wake up
one day and you're like what am I doing
here I think probably everyone listening
is found themselves in that situation
multiple times but I want to go back to
you walking away from the board
and I guess issuing that resignation or
however it came down to it but that day
there were all these cumulative stresses
and we've known each other quite a while
I mean we both like to kind of step up
to bat and take on a lot when we're in
these various projects where we get a
very cool opportunity dangled in front
of us or something we think is cool at
the time and was there a the question I
have is was there a defining moment or
conversation or incident realization
whatever it might have been you know
what was the moment or the day in which
the the the straw was added that broke
the camel's back where you decided like
enough is enough okay
I'm going to walk
yeah so so and I'm not sure what I can
say I'll say this one thing that I I'm
glad I did and and I think I probably
learned this from from from you and some
of the stuff you're talking about when
you negotiate a contract you want to
think about these things in advance
right you want to know like you want to
have a ripcord
in a contract yep that says like hey if
this happens we're walking away and you
but you have to be prepared to do that
and so I was in a position where you
know when when we started to have some
philosophical disagreements about how
things should go I wasn't able to say
hey I disagree you know I was able to
say look we've we've already addressed
this contingency you know it's it's time
for my buyout to come into effect right
so so I I'm glad I did that I think
there was a couple moments you know it
this I
I believe my computer had been hacked at
one point I was very nervous about that
you know I I won't say it was just I was
I was starting to worry about my own
personal security and safety and it's
like there's nothing in there's nothing
in business that is ever worth that
right and then there was an it but if
I'm being perfectly honest it was less
about the situation and more about who I
become when I get drawn into situations
like that like I remember one day I
can't I I got to travel back and forth
commute back and forth from my home on
occasion so I I was I was back in Austin
and I'd come home and I'd written all
these emails on the plane and I was
waiting to get to my house so they would
all send when I got Wi-Fi and I got home
in the internet was down like Time
Warner which is horrible wasn't working
and it wasn't working and I I was
freaking out like I I had a legitimate
panic attack that I couldn't send these
totally meaningless emails at like 11:00
p.m. on a Friday like this is deadly
serious to me and my wife is looking at
me like I'm an insane person and
I'm acting like an insane person and I'm
I'm not I'm taking it out on myself and
on her and and on you know the person in
front of us when we're driving to go to
Starbucks to get internet you know like
I'm just I'm behaving like a an obscene
you know monster basically and and you
know after I calmed that it's like none
of this matters like what am i doing and
so it's like the situation was chaotic
and stressful and I'm I'm glad that I'm
not in it but it would what I've learned
about myself most of all is I you know
it's like look some people can can drink
an unlimited amount and not become an
alcoholic and other people you know they
have one drink and they become somebody
totally different and I'm I'm that way
with stress and chaos and so I've
realized in retrospect like I'm heading
down a very bad road if I choose stress
and chaos over the things that I've
worked really hard to achieve in life
and that I I claim to be important to me
you know like I think I think a lot of
people face that sort of fork in the
road it's like you know are you gonna
choose a life or are you gonna choose
some career or financial or you know
sort of you know accomplishment and
sometimes it works out and sometimes it
doesn't and I think the wake up call for
me was this is this is just not the
person that I want to be well I mean not
to not to throw a really hackneyed
cliche out there but I mean the the fork
in the road that is am I am i working in
order to live or am i living in order to
work right and how what does the
hierarchy of priorities look like and
for in your personal journey
I'd like to dig into one which is the
decision not to live in places that
you're very familiar with like la you
know very well San Francisco New York
City where do you live at the moment and
what's the story with the two miniature
donkeys so I yeah I mean I've lived in
I've lived in New York I've lived in in
in Los Angeles for a long time now I
live right outside Austin my wife and I
we have a small ranch I mean we we have
goats we have miniature donkeys we have
long horn cattle and then like geese and
chickens and dogs and stuff like that
and I think what actually what helped
make the to go back to your other
question what helped make this clear is
it's like you know Here I am living in
somebody else's apartment in Los Angeles
and I'm flying home I still lived in the
city then but I'm flying home to Austin
and it's like this is my life these are
where my books are this like I picked to
live in Austin because I loved Austin
and here this you know there's a job
which is not even my full-time job is
just a you know this thing is pulling me
away from that and I think that tells me
something you know right there but you
know I remember I would I would come
home I was looking at my goats one day
they were in the front yard and they
were just sort of standing there good I
feel like goats do that a lot yeah they
weren't they weren't eating they weren't
you know head-butting each other they
weren't they were standing there and I
remember thinking like they're just
being goats like they don't have a job
like there's nothing that they're
supposed to be doing like they're alive
I and I take care of them they have
nothing you know they're just being
alive and and that reminded me of
something that I dread when you know in
this all this chaos I'd actually started
attending workaholics Anonymous meetings
when I was in in Los Angeles and you
know they say this thing and the
meetings it's like that it's human being
not human doing and it's like yeah the
goat is just supposed to be alive and
here I've told myself that my job is to
you know manage this crisis that I
didn't create that it's impossible for
me to actually solve to make other
people lots of money you know like it is
this what I was put on this earth to do
to be a bundle of stress and and angry
you know nerves like of course not
we're call it synonymous is not
something I have any real familiarity
with and what else helped you from that
experience or did you take away or or
that you remember yeah I mean I took
away I took away a lot it this idea that
your life can become unmanageable
because you you can't
prioritize properly and and that you
can't you can't take care of yourself
and that you can I mean we don't
associate you know sort of stress and
heart attacks and and all these you know
and we don't associate those things with
work because you know work is considered
a good thing and we don't see that it
can become essentially a drug for people
it can become a thing that like if you
think about it this way like let's say
like you're having a terrible day you
know all these things are going wrong
you know what always goes right like you
sitting down at your computer like
sending emails or like reading about
like work is if you're good at what you
do work is the most predictable safe
manageable thing in your life because
like you control it and a lot more than
you control other people or the weather
or all these things right so I think for
me I was I was sort of using it as this
it I could just plug into it in the way
that somebody else might be able to turn
on the television and tune out I could
just plug into it and so that it was a
sort of an awareness of that and then
you know I I had this awakening and you
know tied to the book this idea that
like hey I'm not building this like
monument for all time I'm not like the
world is not revolving around this you
know ridiculous project that I'm you
know working on and and that I don't I'm
the one that's making this feel urgent
and essential and more important than
anything else I I've brought that to the
situation and so I think that was a big
thing I took the other thing I took is
and I don't think people realize this
because they hear workaholism but they
don't realize that it's really the
activity that's the addiction so there's
lots of people who don't work a lot or
maybe they are financially secure so
they don't but you can be an activity
addict too and I certainly pick that up
from my family you know my parents are
always doing things like they live in
Hawaii but they're always doing things
and I think I internalize that as a
young kid it's like I can't relax like I
can't stop and
I just I just realized that that it was
that impulse that had gotten me into
this situation that I then couldn't
figure out how to get out of and the
only way to get out of it was to walk
away so you walk away yeah now do you
still go to work all external meetings
and if not why I found it very hard to
relate to a lot of the people in the
thing mostly being young meaning meaning
you young you were younger than they
most of the attendees yeah yeah they're
I mean I was 27 at the time there's not
a lot of 27 year olds in work all exams
there's calls that you can do I I go to
a therapist who sort of specializes in
this stuff and it's also hard you know
like I know I just sort of told this
harrowing story but the consequences for
me were like very low for all this right
like I didn't destroy my relationship I
didn't you know bet all my money on some
you know ridiculous venture you know I
you know I was I was actually in a great
spot I just committed to too much so the
it wasn't like I was looking at the
wreckage of my life I was I was peering
over the precipice of what could be the
wreckage of my life so um I obviously I
read everything I could on the topic and
then I tend to I go to a therapist now
who sort of specializes in this stuff
and is very familiar with the teachings
of that community so I feel like I sort
of do it that way but you know to go to
your question about but the the decision
to move it to live in Austin to live
outside the city to run my business in
my life a certain way are in in a huge
part just eliminating a lot of the
temptations and influence that would
come from you know having an apartment
in downtown Manhattan and a bustling
marketing firm that is constantly
creating fires that I have to put out
yeah oh I think that the the ware of
happiness is really under examined and
the tendency for type-a personalities I
think I'm guilty of this or have been
and maybe you have at some point is that
I should beware the maximum number of
opportunities are often very ill-defined
or poorly defined this like broad
opportunity bucket and then I should
have the self-control to stave off all
of these impulses with these various
temptations whether it's booze late
nights out people who end up in New York
and have never done cocaine and then end
up doing cocaine socially because they
work in an investment bank and the ABCD
and he happens and I feel like the you
should that is wasteful in some respects
meaning that if you're smart you should
be able to create opportunities as
opposed to being a hundred percent
reactive although there's maybe that's
easier after a certain age and secondly
that so you don't suffer from like
decision fatigue constantly and then
make really bad big decisions to choose
a location where you don't have to
constantly protect yourself from
impulses to reach out and respond to
some shiny distracting object or person
or substance and you know for me San
Francisco is the right fit and for you
it sounds like Austin was the right fit
but let's let's look at to rewind the
clock just a little bit and talk about
the obstacles the way so the obstacles
away comes out and a few things happen I
mean many things happen that I think are
very interesting but one of them is how
quickly it was picked up or widely I
should say it was it was picked up in
this in the professional sports world
and the there was a big piece in Sports
Illustrated about this but can you talk
about the sort of the let's let's start
with the Patriots and then maybe you can
just give a couple of anecdotes about
how its spread and then why you think
it's spread yeah it's it's interesting
you know the obstacles away came out
almost exactly two years ago so we would
have been recording this a little bit
before that the book came out and it was
it was very much because of the
audiobook the audiobook
I guess people in sports love audiobooks
because they travel a lot and and their
their readers are always looking for an
edge but because of I know it was your
podcast and it was also Shane Parrish
who runs Farnam Street he he'd written
something about the book that the book
got very little media attention but
because of outlets like those two a
couple different people in the sports
world picked it up and one of them was
Michael Lombardi who is a special
assistant for the New England Patriots
who's formerly the general general
manager of the Cleveland Browns and he
read the book and he just started giving
it to other people um he emailed me a
couple months later but unbeknownst to
me he'd just given it to other people um
and he and I had started talking I sent
him some more books and then that the
Patriots ended up and I'm not taking
credit for this in any way but the the
the Patriots won the Super Bowl that
year and it was just this sort of it was
it was so amazing for me to be watching
the Super Bowl and knowing that some of
the people involved and that had read my
book but other than that it was a total
secret like no one had talked about it
anything and then the following
offseason Mike met with saw John
Schneider who's the general manager of
the Seahawks who the the Patriots had
beaten at a tryout and he recommended
the book to him and so then the Seahawks
read it and it went through that
organization and so now all of a sudden
my book has been read by both teams who
were in the previous year's Super Bowl
and and from there it just sort of
caught on and not publicly but by word
of mouth I I heard from other from other
other players in the NFL and the NFL
like Garrett Gilkey who plays for the
Bucs and then it started making its way
through baseball then college sports and
in the in basketball Shaka Smart who
became the coach of UT George raveling
was a as a Hall of Fame coach he coached
at USC he actually owns Martin Luther
King's I have a dream speech and now
he's the director of basketball tonight
that's got to be a tough one to enforce
yeah like do you actually chase people
down or using that I have a dream to
inspire their students no no no like he
owns
so he he was a bodyguard for Martin
Luther King on the day he gave the I
have a dream speech on the steps of the
Lincoln is he left George at there's an
amazing article about this George just
asked him if you could have the speech
that oh he owns the original he owns the
the actual Bow Wow it's one of the most
like sort of amazing historical you know
spits of circumstance ever it's so and
he has it in his in his I mean I don't
know where he has it but he has it and
it's in his silverware drawer I it's
it's framed and under you know ten feet
of glass like the US Constitution but um
so it had just made its way through this
through sports and I started Arnold who
I know you've had on the podcast he read
it probably because of your connections
with with people and that's that were
that's mr. Schwarzenegger if people are
wondering which Arnold mmm-hmm sorry
no not hey Arnold but yeah so so it just
started making its way through this
world and I started hearing from people
and and I think you know people go out
and they try to chase so much media
attention and it's if something amazing
is happening
eventually the media will find out about
it and that's what happened a reporter
at Sports Illustrated heard that the
Seahawks were reading and and then we
became friends and then we started
talking and eventually he wrote a piece
about it and now it's been used by all
sorts of other athletes and you know
when I obviously you know when I sat
down to write a book about stoicism and
then when you publish my audio book on
stoicism I don't think either of us were
thinking the target market for this is
is NFL coaches and professional athletes
but in retrospect it makes sort of
perfect sense because the idea of of
having to manage your emotions to think
rationally and clearly and to make the
best of any given situation and sort of
never give up hope it's kind of the
definition of stoicism and the
definition of what professional
athletics are really about at the
highest level yeah no I agree and I'll
give you another story that you have not
heard which is I was recording a podcast
recently with yuta for the Tim Ferriss
show and
the guest was Chris summer Somm er
former national team coach men's
gymnastics and asked him about books
that he had read recently or was reading
that he would recommend and he had no
idea that I knew you and he started
talking about the obstacle that's the
way so that's another another feather in
the in the cap it's so crazy to me
because you know like you write a book
and you want like you can write a book
and and look lots of books so well of
you know somewhat dubious quality right
and so for me like as a writer to know
that people who are way more
accomplished than me who have done
things that I am aghast at and and like
so inspired by that it sort of passes
their test is like all that like the
book could sell zero copies but if like
the ten people who have reached out to
me about it in you know at this sort of
level that they thought it was good
that's like all that matters to me well
I think that it also underscores the the
the observation that Eric Weinstein is a
sort of mathematician and investor he's
managing partner at heel capital I in
works directly under Peter Thiel it was
the first outside investor in facebook
billionaire several times over
co-founder of PayPal etc also Palantir
the point being I he made the point to
me once that generalized fame is
overrated in fact it's undesirable on
many many different levels but selective
fame if you could say pick your three
thousand people to be known among can be
very very useful and you know would you
rather be recognized by the guy waving
the wand and TSA as you walk through or
would you rather be recognized by
everyone in the crowd of Ted but no one
else right and their different
objectives not one is not necessarily
better than the other it's like if
you're if you're going for the former
you need to think very wide and kind of
cross demographic people magazine
television extremely popular cable shows
etc if you're going for the ladder you
can be very surgical and very strategic
and how you set it up and for anyone
who's wondering how this applies to say
product launches or businesses I would
encourage you to read two things the
first is 1,000 true fans by Kevin Kelly
which is an essay online you can read it
for free and then there is also small
Giants I always want I always forget if
it's small or little giants bibo
Burlingham about companies that choose
to be the best and as opposed to the
biggest but they each each of these
companies is highly focused on a small
demographic and I think when you do a
book launch I you can attempt to target
in that way which i think is worth the
effort and planning and identifying
maybe the thousand true fans are 100
true fans or ten true fans in highly
niche areas where those people are
thought leaders right in the case of say
NFL coaches and then paying attention
like really watching maybe verified
accounts on Twitter or whatever it might
be for at mentions to see if a seed has
been planted somewhere that you can help
cultivate right in the case of the NFL
for instance and it's like I've noticed
with the podcast like a handful of NBA
players alright and be a player so
listening flip podcast and some of them
have heard me sort of make jokes in
Spanish because I just live in Argentina
and so like like Ginobili from the Spurs
misheard vodkas and he heard the mint
tea make a mega stone which is this like
lie to me because I like it kind of joke
in Argentine Spanish and you just need
to be observant and follow those things
but if we're looking at a bob servation
learning why why ego I mean yes there
are components of examining the ego in
stoicism for instance but why did you
decide to write about ego and I think
also this this is probably among many
people listening they will have mixed
feelings about that term right they will
feel like it's not a hundred percent
negative nor 100 percent
why did you decide or how did you come
to end up writing about this well sure I
mean look just just I think a very
accessible answer a way to answer that
what you were just talking about the
sort of difference between going huge or
going smaller and influential and then
knowing that you grow from there I think
one of those approaches is probably
driven by ego and the other is driven by
sort of a colder rationality and the
enna and a more sort of Purpose Driven
approach so you know it's when I hear
someone's like oh I want to sell a
million copies
yuria you're like why a million and it
turns out that they just pulled that
number out of their ass or you know they
heard that their friends sold 500,000
and they want to do twice as much right
so it's it's very easy to be motivated
by vanity or ego but it takes discipline
and purpose to know okay these are the
thousand true people that matter to me
and that's what's important and so I
mean part of it just came out of my
experience you know working with you
know in the marketing front and working
with companies and brands seeing how
often you go makes people act in their
own against their own interest sort of
do do destructive but negative or
inexplicable things and so you know
seeing American Apparel collapse that
that sort of brought me closer to this
idea you know seeing you know people I
looked up to and admired you know ruin
things that they built or ruin
relationships that matter to them these
these are these are me sort of you know
over time experiencing some of the
difficulties of ego when I sat down to
write the book I I guess I was thinking
okay if if the obstacle is the way is
about external obstacles which we all
face egos the enemy is about what I
would call our our biggest internal
obstacle which is you know our you know
the the the way in which our pride and
vanity and self-absorption and delusions
and you know need for control and greed
and all these other things that we know
are bad if we the way those things
prevent us from accomplishing what we
want to accomplish our hollowing out
what we do accomplish or you know making
a difficult period in our life even more
difficult I sort of
not saying I'm not talking about ego in
the Freudian sense or you know some
complicated psychological definition I'm
ego it we know you go when we see it
it's you know Bill Walsh another great
football coach he said it's you know
it's it's it's when your ego gets bigger
than your ears that's the problem when
you can't hear the things around you um
Cyril Connelly saying you know ego sucks
us down like the law of gravity I think
we know how ego has ruined people around
us and we know when we've done
egotistical things that have caused
problems in us in our life it's it's
that that I'm talking about not some
general notion of the ego that's the
problem if that if that makes sense so
with if I were trying to then just wrap
my head around it is is ego how much of
ego as discussed in the book is trying
to kill door conform to an image that
you hope others have of you I mean it's
sort of an image reputational driven
issue I I think I think it's a it's a
it's a huge part it's it's this idea of
needing to be needing to be what you've
always wanted to be needing to be what
other people what you want it's it's
it's needing to be the number one the
center of attention you know it's that I
guess it's that sort of like petulant
child
that that needs to get their own way
over anything else or you know it's like
I've got to get I've got to get all the
credit I've got to get all the attention
I need people to know how smart I am I
need I need to be in control and and
sort of seeing every not being able to
see anything bigger than yourself is
probably a decent definition of where
ego becomes a real problem in it so that
starts to distort the rillette like
here's another way to look at it
creativity and and sort of doing great
things I think we both know requires a
real a real connection to reality right
you can't there's an Epictetus quote
where he says one cannot learn that
which they think they already know
so if ego has told you you know
everything all of a sudden it's
impossible for you to learn or if you
think the thing you made is the greatest
thing ever done now all of a sudden
you're not able to sense from the
audience where the improvements need to
come or what changes need to be made or
to make sort of realistic assumptions
about you know your chances of success
these are the way I think the ego
becomes this kind of haze that prevents
us from connecting to the reality that's
so important to doing great work I'm not
saying you can't be ambitious or
optimistic or you know driven by ideals
but it also has to be rooted in in
reality if you hope to accomplish any of
those things let's talk about so I think
the ego pornography integrity or lack
thereof
there there perhaps most easily
Illustrated and defined with examples so
let's talk about one from the book which
is Sherman versus grant could you give
us give us some some context and ten in
they explain that story
sure so so one of my heroes is William
Tecumseh Sherman he was a general in the
Civil War he sort of has this reputation
as being the guy who who destroyed the
south and in a sense he did he's
actually probably the greatest strategic
mind to ever wear a United States
military uniform I think you know you
compare someone like Sherman to a
Napoleon Napoleon is someone who sort of
always believed that he was destined for
greatness that he was the greatest thing
that ever walked the earth he was
deserving of being a dictator right you
compare that to someone like Sherman who
later in his life after the Civil War I
you know was famous for declining the
presidency he was like if nominated I
will not run if elected I will not serve
so he's sort of this opposite of what we
would think of when it comes to the
military he was you know he started very
he started very young he was sort of
constantly underestimated he was setting
all these backwater postings sort of you
know by the time the Civil War broke out
it was like his career
essentially over and he was he was a he
he'd not been successful nobody knew who
he was and it was only in the Civil War
in this sort of immense trial that that
he showed himself to be this strategic
genius and he sort of earned his place
at the the top of the heap and there's
this wonderful quote from from one of my
favorite biographers his name is BH
Liddell Hart I talked about him a little
bit in ago but he's just this brilliant
writer there's a world war 1 hero and he
talks about actually I have it he says
he's sort of the the difference but he's
like he's saying there's the difference
between the kind of people who are pop
you know utterly confident about the
things they're gonna achieve in life and
the other people who sort of whose image
is a is a slow accumulation based on
achievement and and he says like the
last type their own success is a
constant surprise and therefore like the
fruits are more delicious and then he
says you know in that is poised and not
posed and so I think we tend to think
eat oh is this like braggadocio and and
and boldness and and whatever and we we
sort of discount the problems that that
has and I what I like about someone like
Sherman is that it was his sense of
himself has grown confidence when he
decides to to do this march to the sea
which was in many ways counter to a lot
of military theory at the time he's
abandoning his supply lines his he's not
doing that based on ego he's doing it
based on confidence which he earned he
earned it based on his actual
performance the the work that he put in
the knowledge that he built over time
and then the other story I tell him the
book related to Sherman and Grant so at
the at the end of the Civil War grant
who's also here of mine Sherman and
grant are basically the two most famous
men in America they're you know they're
they're their war heroes they're they've
led armies of millions of men at the end
of the war
Sherman decided continues to be a
soldier he serves for a few more years
and then he retires basically and what
amounts to happiness and Sherman arts
are in Grant who did not know politics
at all in fact was a good general
because he was so bad
politics decides to run for president
he's elected in a landslide and then
serves two of the probably the worst
terms in u.s. presidential history he
was surrounded by corruption because he
wasn't you know sort of good at sussing
people out that way
reconstruction stalls he's just a bad
president and I say that as someone who
admires him he's a bad president he
leaves the presidency and then he opens
a financial brokerage with his with his
son and a partner that partner turns out
to be like the Bernie Madoff of his day
and he loses all his money he ends up
having to essentially put up his war
mementos to earn money to pay off the
investors and then he writes his memoirs
as he's dying of cancer to to leave his
family something to live on and there's
this letter from Sherman to someone
Sherman is saying you know grant grant
was this great hero and yet he tried to
make he he he pursued these things that
he had no skills in you know being the
president and then he's saying Sherman
is saying like you know he he he tried
to make money to impress people who
would have given all the money in the
world to have won one of grants battles
and that that really hit home to me
because I you know sort of just gone
through this stuff in my life it's like
wait he'd done this miraculous thing but
because he couldn't understand how
impressive it was and he had this
endless need to impress other people he
ended up losing everything to impress
people who were already impressed with
him and to me I think that's such a
great example of where ego can take us
it it takes us so far past our
capabilities and our needs because it's
insatiable and and you know Grant died a
painful sad death and at a young age and
and I think you have to attribute that
ego to part of that
well it brings a couple of things to
mind and then I have a question for you
which relates to the question of why
right so the the we have the
characteristics of their respective
careers one in
I think retrospect clearly more
desirable than the other but you know
what made them different is the question
I'm gonna come back to but the I guess
they're a few observations is one and I
might be getting this quote slightly
wrong but I've heard this said I'm gonna
paraphrase it here before which is we
work doing things we don't like to get
money we don't need to impress people we
don't like yeah that's kind of the first
one which i think is related to you know
the engine that drives that disaster is
ego as discussed earlier a component of
which being caring a lot about what
other people think and then the other is
actually pulled from I just pulled up
the PDF of some of my line notes because
for those people who don't have the
background I read a very early
manuscript of the egos then the egos the
enemy and went through and and really
just digested every single line and
highlighted things that I found
particularly appealing or helpful and
one of them was I'm gonna probably
pronounce this incorrectly but the
performance artist Marina Abramovic
I'm guessing puts it directly yeah quote
if you start believing in your greatness
it is the death of your creativity end
quote so I think that could be a very
much related piece of it sure there's a
line in in in billions which Brian
Koppelman who's I think yeah great show
the creator of yeah and it's at the end
of the season and and the guys just made
this sort of disastrous bet axe has and
the therapist is asking him why and he's
like when people call you Superman long
enough you start to think that you're
Superman and I think I think with Grant
it is like he'd just won one of the
greatest military victories in in
history and then Viswa ego is so toxic
he just sort of defied all of the odds
he remade the world literally like
changed the course of history with his
sheer persistence and and you know he
didn't listen to the doubters so like
part of doing a great thing is that you
are you are you know putting a middle
finger up to whatever one
is saying and that it that works except
for when you're wrong that's when it
leads to disastrous things so like I'm
sure people were like you know like
Ulysses like don't run for president
like you're not good at this like it's
not gonna end well or like what do you
know about Wall Street why are you
creating a financial firm you know and
it's that it's when we bulldoze right
over those those really reasonable
questions because we we can't say no to
things or we want things to badly that's
where we overreach we believe in our own
greatness like that quote is saying
that's the death of our of our
connection to the reality which is what
made us good in the first place so the I
was I was given some advice I think it
was just in the first week or two that
the 4-hour workweek hit the New York
Times bestseller list 2007 I suppose it
must have been and I was told you never
just remember you're never as good as
they say you are and you're never as bad
as they say you are and so if I've I've
repeated that to myself quite a lot in
good and bad times right and I'm just
looking at this marked a PDF again and
you have demonicus right you have a
number of quotes but one is abhor
flatterers as you would deceivers for
both if trusted injure those who trust
them and yeah there's there's a little
there's a lot to dig into there but
let's talk about someone who is lionized
by many people and perhaps unright least
so and I should also highlight the point
that and we'll probably get into this
that I think believing you are the
greatest and sort of drinking that
kool-aid believing your own hype that
doesn't preclude you necessarily from
being financially successful because I
think that many people will say well
what about this person what about this
other person who has clearly an enormous
ego I mean they're on television talking
about how great they are and how
brilliant there are constantly and what
I've noticed at least is there there is
there's a big difference between
financial and career success as
subjectively defined by the masses or by
any of us somebody who has a lot of
money and gets seen on TV a lot
for instance and someone who is even
remotely content or Pleasant as a human
being to themselves and others and it's
been my observation at least in Silicon
Valley that the people who tend to like
bang their chests the most and make the
most noise are very rarely the people
who left alone for 10 minutes to sit
with themselves who are happy with what
they see or can even sit still at all I
mean they tend to end up being pretty
miserable for the most part but getting
ahead of myself
Howard Hughes no no no look I think
that's a great point and that's
something I've thought about a lot in
the book because people always go like
you know what about Steve Jobs or what
about Kanye West and I think one of the
distinctions you have to make is just
because someone is successful to you
that doesn't mean that they have
accomplished what they are trying to
accomplish or what's important to them
so if you look at someone like Kanye
West clearly a musical genius clearly
one of the greatest rappers to ever live
he's made amazing work like and then
when you know his last album came out of
a few months ago or I think it's sort of
in this weird release thing that he's
doing but you know he's admitting that
he's like millions of dollars in debt
because like this fashion line that he
keeps trying to launch like isn't
working and I would argue that it's
probably because his ego is most out of
control there whereas he put in so many
hours previously on his music when he
was you know aspiring to do this thing
as a kid that he's so talented that it's
able to compensate for this monstrous
ego right and so I think in in some ways
it's like ego is dangerous when you're
aspiring to something no question but it
it's when you're successful and you've
built this thing and then you're trying
to do your next thing when you're
convinced that everything you do touches
to go everything you touch turns to gold
that's where ego is the most destructive
because it's like door trying to do this
other thing you're already rich famous
you know talented you've done this great
work but ego is is they're shutting that
door in your face and that's not as
visible to the rest of
public in the way that it is you know
when we see some young kid implode
before they've been able to accomplish
what they're trying to accomplish let's
let's talk about Howard Hughes for a sec
and what is your opinion of Howard
Hughes so I think Howard uses a great
example of actually we're just talking
about in the sense that you know most
people who are egotistical they try
something and they fail right and then
we never hear from them again it's sort
of their edited out by the survivorship
bias right like we don't hear from the
people that tried to do something and
then never made it onto our radar Howard
Hughes is a great example of someone
because he had millions ultimately
billions of dollars passing his way
through the the the monopolies that his
father had created in the oil drilling
business he was able to repeated
repeatedly fail and waste hundreds of
billions and again ultimately billions
of dollars in his own lifetime on these
ridiculous he I think you could argue
although he was clearly a genius pilot
and and a wonderful inventor he was
arguably one of the worst businessmen of
the 20th century I mean he lost tens of
millions of dollars in the stock market
speculating on stocks he he owned RKO
Pictures which had like thousands of
tens of thousands of employees when he
bought it and ended with like a couple
hundred he lost you know I think
something like twenty million dollars in
in terrible movies with RKO he the
Spruce Goose which he was so famous for
in that movie aviator he built this huge
plane out of out of wood like it's a
it's an interesting project but you
don't realize like hey that was a you
know a twenty million dollar government
contract for a plane that was late that
flew one time and then he stored it in a
warehouse for forty years and a million
dollars a year right like you don't
realize that Howard Hughes he did all
these he did sort of these Elon Musk
esque projects that were inspiring and
bold and they almost never came to
anything and the only reason he was
never really held accountable for any of
them is the fact that she at Hughes Tool
Company which was what his father
created which
after his father's death Howard fused
and literally never stepped foot in ever
again was the was the cushion from which
all these preposterous ly egotistical
failures would land upon and you know
ultimately at the end of his life he had
some mental illnesses but dick
they even traced most of his mental
illnesses back to plane and car crashes
which he caused by being reckless right
so I see him as this sort of cautionary
figure in Elon Musk has actually said um
that he sees Howard Hughes's as a
cautionary tale it's someone who was so
incredibly talented and had so much
potential but had very little discipline
and order and and object objectivity in
his life and it ultimately ended in a
very very bad place for him and you know
when I read a really great book on
Howard Hughes called Howard Hughes his
life and madness I read this right
around the time you know the American
Apparel stuff was happening and I it it
was it was deeply even uncomfortable for
me to read seeing some of those those
similarities behind this kind of
visionary genius on the one hand but
also their own worst enemy on the other
and and watching those two forces battle
each other so two questions the first is
let's just say that you sat down with
Howard Hughes at what point would to to
provide him with advice or he actually
wanted to solicit advice from you and
let's just also assume that he is open
to that advice right so maybe he time
traveled hung out with Steve Jobs and
took some LSD and what advice would you
give him and is there any particular
point in time or how would you try to
correct course I don't want to dodge
your question but I would imagine you
relate to what I'm gonna say have you
ever looked because you know your you
you've got your people like famous or
important or wealthy people will
sometimes reach out to authors and you
know invite them to their house or even
pay them for like a consulting session
where you serve they want your advice on
some project they're working on or
sure and so I found myself in situations
like that you know you're called to
someone's mansion or their penthouse
apartment you get there and this is
someone you've admired you thought had
it together you know you're you're very
um you know you're a fan of their work
or you know you're you're envious of
what they've accomplished and you get
there and and you know they're ranting
and I've seen them in you know these
sort of manic fits they're ranting and
raving about these things it's like hey
you know they're obsessed with what some
person on a tiny blog said about them or
they're you know they're they're there
they're there they're convinced that
they have to do this thing or they you
know they're like I'm doing this project
and I want it to be the big you know I
want it to sell a hundred million copies
and you're just like with all your
knowledge you just know that that thing
is impossible right and you so often you
see it's like man this person this
person has become so successful you you
realize that to give this person the
truth would be a kamikaze mission you
would like to tell them what you
actually felt or thought or what they
what you thought they needed to know
would implode any chance of you working
together and so I I see ego doing that I
think you definitely saw that with
Howard Hughes he would be this guy he
would had he'd be waging the corporate
takeover of you know TWA and then also
writing a thick tating a thousand word
memo about how employees shouldn't look
at him in the eye right or that you know
how no one should touch anything without
putting a Kleenex between their hand and
the doorknob you know he was this person
who I don't know how you got ahold of my
my prep sheet for guest to my house but
we can talk about that later we you know
you know what I mean I'm you get calls
to you you real it's very sad you're
like this is this is in some ways
hopeless because like imagine if Richard
Nixon had called you and asked you for
advice you're like dude you really
backed yourself into a corner here like
you you shouldn't have done any of this
this is insane and the only it you know
they themselves just a few years you
know before after would have would it
would be able to see that
but they're so caught up in the moment
in there they the they were you know
they were similar to how I was when I
was you know wound way too tight and it
way over committed they they're not able
to step back and see what's happening
with any measure of of realism and I
think that's that's the kind of thing
that happened to someone like Howard
Hughes John DeLorean who's another hero
of people it's like he ran his own
company in the ground and then he
thought he could try to save it with a
60 million dollar cocaine deal it's like
this is not this is not the rational
mind thinking this is ego and full sway
convincing you that you're untouchable
you know convincing you to do bad stupid
reckless things well let's look at then
maybe take a different tack what do you
see is the biggest differences between
Elon Musk and Howard Hughes does the
Elon Musk is very good at executing I've
been very fortunate to meet him maybe
two times two or three times briefly but
it seems very highly rational and I'm
gonna I'm gonna give also a bit of a
tease for one of my one of the
paragraphs that I underlined in egos
enemy which is it begins as follows and
I'm not trying to I'm not trying to hand
you this as the answer so feel free I
want to hear other thoughts but a young
basketball player named Lewis Alcindor
junior who want three national
championships with John Wooden at UCLA
use one word to describe the style of
his famous coach dispassionate okay so I
found Elon to be very dispassionate but
in a confidence inspiring way and he
also has a meticulous so I got some kind
of answering my own question a little
bit but meticulous attention to detail
which I'm sure Hughes that in some
respects meticulous attention to detail
in the same way that wouldn't had so
wouldn't I heard a a anecdote about him
which went roughly as follows when he
had new recruits to the team he would
sit them down and he would walk them
through how to unlace and lace their
shoes
and sure I don't know if you've heard
this story and the okay and the reason
being he said if you if you lace your
shoes improperly you get blisters
blisters cause shots cause games miss
games our lost games cause seasons right
and he just had this meticulous
attention to detail even with the unsexy
aspects but what would you say the
biggest differences otherwise from
saying Hughes and monster well well
related to that another story that I've
heard about Elon Musk and I think it's
in that big biography of him but I read
it in a Business Insider article but it
was when he was starting SpaceX
originally they were thinking they were
gonna buy these rockets and then build
this sort of rocket company right and
that's what a sort of a dispassionate
person would be like that's the idea
we've got the money we're jumping into
it let's go let's go let's go and that's
that sort of that manic mindset of I'm
rich I'm famous I'm Elon Musk I can do
whatever I want but that's not what Elon
must did they they got quotes on the
Rockets and they're incredibly expensive
and Elon Musk did a thinking exercise
which comes from from Aristotle called
going to first principles and he sort of
cautioned the team he was like look you
guys have got to what let's actually
look at what building a rocket costs so
instead of saying like hey this is what
these you know defense companies would
charge for rocket what does it cost to
make a rocket they did the math and it
turned out they could make their own
rockets for like 10% of the cost of what
they could buy them and so SpaceX really
comes from that very simple thinking
exercise and that's obviously what John
what John Wooden isn't it there's a
story about a football coach I forget
who it is but you know he calls the team
in and he it might be a limb Barty and
and he picks up the the football he's
got the team gathered and it goes this
men is a football right it's like these
people they've been playing it their
entire lives and he's like this is what
a football is that's going to first
principles to almost an absurd degree
right this is how you tie your shoes and
Elon Musk is saying hey let's actually
do the math on what this company should
be and do
and what what we're gonna be making and
what it cost let's not just take other
people's premises for granted and let's
also not make decisions based on our
presuppositions and our emotions and so
I think you know not knowing Elon Musk
and not knowing a ton about him I would
say one of the things that he's at least
done thus far and who knows he could
blow it all up tomorrow he's he's been
very rational and he does these things
step by step and I think you know he
didn't launch Tesla in this X he like he
even looked at someone like John
DeLorean and looked at the mistakes that
he made and we thought it and when he
launched Tesla he was learning from that
experience rather than needing to make
those costly errors himself so I think
that sort of dispassion that objectivity
that that willingness to go to first
principles is certainly something that
is has made him incredibly successful so
far and I think the critic from wrong
but the the bio that has been
recommended to me a few times now which
I have not yet read I'm embarrassed to
say is Elon Musk
Tesla speaks a space X and the quest for
a fantastic future by Ashley Vance yes
so there's a there's there are a number
of points in your writing across
multiple books where you talk about the
importance of not only accepting
critical feedback but soliciting
critical feedback right I'd like to
bring up a term that I mentioned for the
first time publicly a few months ago in
conversation with Eric Weinstein which
was bigoted ear right and the the the
basic definition of a bigoted ear being
someone who seeks to profit in some way
from calling other people bigots whether
it be sexist racist film in the blank
right
whether that's simply getting attention
for themselves dry driving clicks to a
particular article because that's how
they're compensated could be any number
of things material or otherwise
but the the reason I thought having a
term like that it was important the
gatir and and we may bounce around a
little bit in this particular as it
relates to this question but is that
there are people who currently would
call themselves were called social
justice warriors where there's no real
negative consequence for hurling these
terms around that can cause a lot of
damage right and and you've written an
article separately about I guess it was
help me out here Fahrenheit 451 and and
it was about protecting everyone's
feelings and the problem with trying to
protect everyone's feelings and how that
can backfire and so maybe you could
start with the one of the common myths
remembrances of Fahrenheit 451 which is
who actually mandates that the books get
burned how did that start
sure yeah I mean so everyone reads
Fahrenheit 451 in high school and and I
think the takeaway is like Oh firemen
are burning books because like a
controlling government is asking them to
do that and when I read the book again
about a year ago and and you realize
that actually in the and and Captain BD
I think it's the is that the name I'm
forgetting but that the the captain he
tells him no look we do this because the
public doesn't like to be offended the
public doesn't like to be upset that's
why we ban books it's not a government
mandate it's a mandate from the people
for the government to enforce getting
rid of ideas that are unpleasant and so
the Fahrenheit 451 takes on this new
light in that sense you're realizing
that it's it's the desire not to offend
that drives most censorship most
censorship is not controlling its
well-meaning and I think it all stems
from this idea that someone um my wife
says it's I'll be like you're
frustrating me and she's like someone
can't frustrate you like you can be
frustrated but someone you no one has
the power over you to frustrate you
that's something you have and that's a
very stoic idea
Epictetus he says if someone succeeds in
provoking you the
the the problem is you not them your he
says your mind is complicit in the
provocation and I think that's a good
that's a good luck that that's what we
have trouble accepting so like it's not
it's not the person you know it's like
hey that's offensive to those other
people don't say that it's not those
people standing up and saying I'm
offended it's it's us trying to be this
sort of thought police protecting all
these other people and so I think what
we've seen at least media wise
especially when we're in this
environment that's so driven by clicks
and traffic is people see someone else
do something that could be interpreted
as offensive so they interpret it as
offensive and they write about it and
then they rile other people up so like
you know Curt Schilling is a
professional baseball player just got
fired by ESPN like two days ago
for for for posting some dumb thing on
Facebook that I totally disagree with
and it's totally offensive and
close-minded but it's like why like he
did not say it on television he said it
on his private Facebook page which she
should probably be allowed to do and
also you know we live in a world of Isis
and Donald Trump and all these other
things is this really the target that
you want to go after and so I think you
know what what we're seeing ray bradbury
said there's there's more than one way
to burn a book it's not just this overt
censorship it's this idea that we need
to we need to protect everyone's
feelings be hyper sensitive all the time
be pressing the you know the outrage
button constantly it exhausts people and
it makes it I think ironically very hard
to deal with some actually alarming or
offensive or dangerous ideas you know
out there in the world or you know
currently running for president or no I
agree I and it's in this conversation
just so people don't think we've gone
off the reservation into sort of
political speak these are closely
related to the individual self
regulation using or conditioning using
stoicism for instance right I mean it's
just a macro example but the macro is
just
a conglomeration of the micro right and
I mean one of my most popular most
retweeted liked tweets in the last two
years was if you're offended easily
you're a bad resource allocator it's a
waste of energy and attention which is a
greater sin than wasting time and so if
you're trying to be a good resource
allocator right and you recognize that
your mind is complicit in the
provocation if you allow yourself to get
upset unnecessarily excessively well two
things I would say the first is that my
greatest fear I'm speaking it to a group
of students at UCLA a few months ago and
they want to talk about artificial
intelligence and the dangers and the
promises of artificial intelligence the
threats of say whether it be Isis or
other types of existential threats
towards humankind right and by how I
would kind of rank order them and so on
which I have no credibility for
answering but I do spend a lot of time
around people in Silicon Valley and
technologists who do have a good read on
these things and I said my biggest
concern for the u.s. specifically is the
existential death of free speech driven
by among other people college students
who are going on witch hunts sure and
with this very Fahrenheit 451 type
mentality where like anyone who who
causes discomfort anyone who offends
anyone who god forbid questions the
accusations of you know racist sexist
fill in the blank or asks us at least
how we are defining these terms should
be you know lynched from a career
standpoint at the very least and that
that is my biggest fear is that we're
slowly going to I kind of choke the life
out of free speech and First Amendment
in the United States with this like
death of paper cuts where it's not
against the law to speak your mind but
it might as well be because the the
public has become so sort of trigger shy
and aversive to on
conversation that that is the knee-jerk
response sure I mean like I think it's
like you know if someone told you that
saying something was illegal you'd
probably still say it just like you
speed or you know huge you do you break
other tiny laws but it's like if someone
told you like hey if you talk about this
subject everyone on the internet is
gonna hate you and boycott your things
and you know get your clients to fire
you and pull your advertisers away
you're like well I'm probably not gonna
say that I think Scott Adams he had a
great thing because he's always getting
in trouble he was saying the creator of
Dilbert for those people who don't
reckon it yep he's saying that you know
being creative is like drilling for oil
sometimes you miss sometimes you find it
and he's like sometimes the sometimes it
catches on fire you know and and we have
to be willing for that to happen and if
we're not if we don't understand that
hey sometimes smart people say dumb
things you know sometimes it's much more
complicated than the two-minute
soundbite you know 500 word blog post
that you read sometimes you know people
are deliberately misleading you I
remember all these people that were
super mad at you know remember a few
years ago Cheryl Sherrod who was a you
know an african-american woman who
supposedly been caught saying something
racist and Breitbart posted a video and
then she was fired like personally by
the President and then it turned out
that the video had been like you know
misleadingly edited yeah or whole food
just got in trouble last week here in
Austin because someone accused them of
you know writing a gay slur on a cake
for a gay wedding and then the security
footage so far has revealed that it
wasn't on the cake when it left the
store and that this guy might be trying
to shake them down for money and so you
don't getting pissed off immediately
before you all know all the facts is bad
not being able to understand nuance is
bad and not being empathetic that like
hey we all you know I've heard my
parents say dumb things I've heard my
grandparents say anachronistic offensive
things you know that's just that's part
of life and if you get provoked
not helping the situation you're
probably making it worse yeah and I I
where I wanted this to lead was asking
you well let me make a plea to the
audience that is number one have the
uncomfortable conversations if you get
unfairly accused of fill-in-the-blank
hissed don't respond with I am not fill
in the blank right I respond with that's
actually that seems really outrageous to
me how are you defining ex forced them
to define and you will find out very
quickly nine times out of ten they
cannot do a good job or they just end up
making themselves look ridiculous so
don't fight someone or debate someone
before you make them fight themselves
and debate themselves because they'll
very often just punch themselves out so
that'd be number one and number two is
don't and I was given this advice
actually by I'm not going to name names
here but a very high-level kind of
political adviser I was having dinner
with at one point we had some wine I was
talking about various initiatives and so
on that I wanted to undertake including
supporting research related to
psilocybin at Johns Hopkins and trying
to change the legal status and blah blah
blah blah blah there quite a few things
and he said well that's a big long list
he said you should assume he said that
you have if one gun has six bullets you
get six bullets a year he's like any
more than that it's a gift to aim at the
right targets any more than that and you
make people kind of deaf dumb and blind
to your pleas and to your messages if
you're constantly hitting people and you
should feel that way yourself that you
like by complaining or being offended
easily number one you're wasting your
own resources and making your life worse
not better number two for the real
things that matter you have let's just
say six bullets a year so like save the
ammo for the right targets but I'm gonna
get off my soapbox here and I want to
ask you Ryan what do you do in terms of
practices routines to instill in
yourself these the characteristics that
you would like to have as it relates to
stoicism or ego
what how does someone improve themselves
in other words but I want to hear your
personal approach yeah I I think I I
think journaling is important so every
morning when I wake up I III write in
animal Skeena I do about two pages and I
write not just what happened the last
day sort of how I feel about it and what
what I'm working on it I feel like if
you don't know what you're like you know
I want to be less sensitive or I want to
be more empathetic or you know I want to
I want to stop losing my temper and you
know you sort of write these things down
it's it's it's you're you're having to
articulate your goal it's not just this
sort of vague notion one of the other
things I write two things that are
really important in my diary so one I
write my the amount of time that I spent
exercising the day before which keeps me
accountable and I find that I do a lot
of sort of work on myself I feel that
flow state is very meditative I do a
little bit of meditating but I really
feel like like I do distance running and
so I feel like my distance running is my
form of meditation but the other thing I
started writing down and this is after I
read Cal Newports book deep work I
record how many hours I spent in deep
work the previous day and one of the
things that helps keep me accountable
with some of my you know my my problems
getting distracted and overwhelmed is if
that's not if that tally is in three or
four hours like I didn't spend three or
four hours really working on like my
actual creative important projects then
I know I over committed to phone calls
meetings you know running errands I'm
not managing my life really well and so
being writing these things down has
helped me keep me really accountable the
other thing is actually writing and
talking about these ideas like
ironically you know you write a book
about stoicism then you write a book
about ego it's very people are gonna not
be very forgiving with me if I complain
about stuff or I you know I blame other
people for my problems or if I like I
even have to think as I'm marketing this
book like you know if I say something
that sounds very you get too
like somebody's gonna call me out about
it on Twitter like I think being
somewhat public with what you care about
and what you're working on is it are two
other ways I think to attack some of
these well doing anything with social
accountability right I mean you can have
sure the you have to have consequences
or I should say incentives right like
economics is the study of incentives I
mean in its simplest form and in that
case I mean same limit I mean personally
I can also say like for our body or the
4-hour workweek blessings end a curse
but it's like if I'm in a coffee shop on
a laptop for more than like three
minutes somebody's gonna walk by take a
photo of me make a [ __ ] four-hour joke
and like put on the internet it's like I
have to be like yeah if you got it
horrible it's like I can't be fat I
cannot be fat so that's great I'm not
allowed to be fat it's it's just the I
would never live it down that you don't
need to write books to have this type of
social accountability you can create a
betting pool you can for instance for
weight loss so you could have four or
five people put in a hundred dollars
each and the person who loses the most
body fat key not just scale so you can
use DEXA scans for this or any number of
different tools then wins the entire
pool right what's cool about that is you
will actually work harder to not lose
your hundred dollars and to beat the
other people then you will to earn the
500 or 600 whatever it might be right so
that could be one example another would
be using a site like coach taught me or
stick stic cake a.com
diet bet is another just gonna rattle
off a few another would be simply making
generally subconscious responses more
conscious and so for instance I think
something that is very helpful for both
implementing stoic practices in a very
kind of proactive proactive that's a new
word proactive operating system type
sense where you it's a it's a system for
making better decisions end in a way to
address ego in in quite a few different
manifestations is to do in
complaint experiment where you have say
and this is from will Bauer whose
Reverend I believe or preacher the very
least has a large congregation and he
puts up a rubber band effectively or a
bracelet on one arm and you you're not
allowed to complain for 21 days and
every time you complain you snap it on
your wrist you put it on the other wrist
and the clock starts over 21 days
without complaining and people can
search 21 day no complaint experiment in
my name if you want more on that but the
point being I think that it's it's quite
one thing to read about these things
which is very important I think you need
to have like the owner's manual and to
deductively or inductively right whether
you're going from concepts to examples
or examples to concepts in grain this
and have a firm understanding of it but
then it when the rubber hits the road
you have to actually condition yourself
and practice this just like you would go
running just like you would meditate in
the morning use an app like headspace
just like you would commit to scheduling
anything else you need to make this a
practice I think and that's where a lot
of people fail is with any type of
nonfiction or how-to and I've certainly
done this myself as you read the book
you're like great so happy I check that
off and then you put it down like six
months later you're like oh yeah that
book Wow I haven't done anything that
was in that book so what what advice
would you give to people who want to
make the leap from the written page to
real life any other any other thoughts
yeah look I think that that's the tough
part how does how does how does
knowledge become experience there's a
there's a quote I think I use in the
book but it's from Plutarch he was
talking about
I actually I forget what he's talking
about but basically saying it was not so
much from the words that I got the
knowledge it was from my experience of
the words I'm butchering this quote it's
horrible but basically he was saying
look it wasn't my it wasn't the words
that help me with my experiences it was
the experiences that I brought to the
words that help me understand them in a
new way and I think so it's got to be
this mix like if you're not if you're
not leaving a book or you know something
you've read if you're not leaving it
with a okay now I'm going to do X
because
of this then you know it your your just
pursuing it for its own sake I don't
want to say it's it's masturbation but
it's closed right like um you're not
you're not you're not you're not
achieving anything you just spent a year
reading up you know a week reading a
self-improvement book but tell it's like
tell me what you're gonna do with this
information and so you know I think
that's what you're that's what you've
constantly got to do whatever your
reading whatever your thinking is okay
I'm now going to put this thing into
practice it doesn't have to be a huge
thing it can be the smallest possible
thing but if you don't leave with some
sort of actionable thing you're really
just deluding yourself and and I think
but it's like look you can read a book
about Brazilian Jujitsu
that doesn't make you that doesn't make
you any better at it it's only if you
you know you you try that out on the mat
and against another human being that's
gonna lead to any sort of real
improvements got to become it's got to
become muscle memory especially if you
intend you know it was stoicism it's if
if you're not applying these things in a
small way and insignificant situations
what are the chances that you're gonna
be able to do it in an extremely adverse
stressful overwhelming situation it's
very it's very slim slim to none yeah so
the the Plutarch quote I think this is
it for it was not so much that by means
of words I came to a complete
understanding of things is that from
things I somehow had an experience which
enabled me to follow the meaning of
words that is a tough one to remember
yeah but to your point then this is one
of my favorite quotes
I think it's arc and locus is how you
would say it but we we do not rise to
the level of our hopes we fall to levels
of our training and so my experience
with training let's just use the
athletic example you have planning right
or programming where you have planning
then you have then you have practice and
then you have reflection or review and
that review piece is very important so
I'm gonna underscore something you said
about journaling there's a there's a
there's a book called the five minute
journal which you can
I use pretty much every morning and
every evening two and a half minutes in
the morning two and a half minutes at
night to accomplish two things all right
to to have a clarity on this kind of
prep and review portion of the day
practice being the rest of the day in
between also to cultivate the practice
of gratitude and actually writing down
three even three things that you're
grateful for each day including one that
is very small not anything necessarily
all-encompassing like the health of my
friends and family right that's
fantastic but you can very quickly go on
autopilot and just list that off every
day and I've talked this about this
before my morning routine so I won't be
labor here but the point being that when
I've spent time with say Tony Robbins
for instance who is one of the most I
think effective is certainly impressive
interventionists when it comes to
personal crises that I've ever seen in
my life it's really fun it's just
mind-blowing what this guy can
accomplish in a handful of minutes with
someone he's never met before and he he
has said before and it really made sense
when I started reflecting on this that
most of our suffering and misery comes
from a focus on me it's just a self
focus and I think that this gratitude
helps to relieve that pressure in that
compulsion somewhat so that that
journaling I think is particularly
important well Brian I know we're
probably coming up on time here is there
anything that you would like to leave
people with anything for them to think
about or to consider to take with them
yeah I mean I liked what you were just
saying about Tony I think that's really
interesting it's this idea that is it's
one it's when you make something all
about you it you stop seeing it
rationally and I think the other thing I
found that that was helpful for me it's
this idea of like this thing like well
however many copies of my book sells or
however much money I make or whoever I
know none of the it's like if you can if
you could start to realize that none of
these things say anything about you
as a person right and I think that's why
we get so caught up it's like we're like
the kind of car I Drive says something
about me as a person you know like the
number of Twitter followers I have says
something about me as a person so then
we're like so possessive and aggressive
and ambitious and controlling about them
because like we've we've wrapped our
identity up in them when I was first
writing the book the original title is
based on a quote from Paul Graham where
he says keep your identity small because
the smaller your identity the more able
your the the more you're able to be
flexible and adaptive and creative and
and you know see see changes in
disruption coming in the world and so I
think this idea of wrapping our identity
up in our work or you know in in
material things what what things that
the Stoics would put in the category of
you know what we don't control that's
where we start to get in serious trouble
because now you know something can
always threaten that thing someone can
repossess your car you know your someone
can give you a negative review on your
book and now all of a sudden you're
reacting super negatively and
emotionally and angry and and that's
when you do things that you're not proud
of you're here right training yourself
to value most of the things that cannot
be taken away totally and and I think
that's that's a scary idea for people
but it's it's ultimately very freeing
right because you're you're immune to
the fluctuations of events that doesn't
mean that you can't live in a nice house
and you know you can't have fun and you
can't be you can't have things that
you're trying to accomplish but you want
I think cultivate that resilience that
like hey you know if I had to start over
tomorrow I would still be me and I would
have all the skills that I bring to the
table and I'd be I'd be pretty good that
to me that's much better than like you
know being Richard Nixon ranting on the
White House tapes about all these people
who are trying to screw them over you
know it's stay out of politics this the
corollary but yeah unless well yeah
unless you're unless you're perhaps a
Sherman who in the first place doesn't
want to be in politics but would
probably do the best job the irony of
the Asian which we live but
Brian this is always a pleasure I loved
being reminded always of the the first
principles in some ways of living the
good life
whether that's choosing to use certain
things as tools that make terrible
masters whether that's money possessions
otherwise and really keeping in mind as
opposed in many ways just the serenity
prayer and this the the the two very
separate buckets of things that you can
control things you can't control
and then working methodically
dispassionately very often on the things
that you can control because I mean
these these little actions cumulatively
are the big actions and I suppose on
that note I will thank you for taking
the time really appreciate it thank you
for having me it's always good and for
everyone who is wondering about show
notes links to everything that we have
discussed of course ego is the enemy and
many other things different figures and
so on you can find those all in the show
notes at four hour work week comm
forward slash podcast and until next
time thank you for listening hey guys
this is Tim again just a few more things
before you take off number one this is
five bullet Friday do you want to get a
short email from me will you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
Friday that provides a little morsel of
fun before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up
I hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by fresh books fresh
books is used by a ton of the startups
that I work with or advice many of the
fastest growing it is used by almost all
of the contractors that I work with it
is the easiest way online to send
invoices get paid track your time for
invoicing track your clients so they get
to the point of paying you all that
stuff that you could possibly find and
right now you can get a free month of
complete unrestricted use and you do not
need a credit card for the trial to
claim your free month just go to
FreshBooks com forward slash Tim and
enter Tim in the how did you hear about
us section you can of course customize
it to fit your brand with your own logo
in color and fresh book shows you
whether or not for instance a client has
looked at the invoice they can send late
payment reminders to your clients
automatically so you do not have to
think about it or chase them down and
you can track your hours you can do all
sorts of things there our mobile app
lets you take pictures of your receipts
and freshbooks will organize them for
you later it is a great piece of
software and if you are in a small
business or maybe a fast growing
business that is feeling growing pains
and you need to streamline then this is
a place to look because certainly for me
this has been a headache in the past and
it doesn't have to be a headache for you
let's check out fresh ebooks.com forward
slash Tim and try it out and see what
you think this episode is brought to you
by wealthfront and this is a very unique
sponsor wealthfront
is a massively disruptive in a good way
set it and forget it
investing service led by technologists
from places like Apple and world-famous
investors it has exploded in popularity
in the last two years and they now have
more than two and a half billion dollars
under management in fact some of my very
good friends investors in Silicon Valley
have millions of their own money in
wealth front so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that in a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront com forward slash
Tim take the risk assessment quiz which
only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio
they put you in and if you just want to
take their advice run with it do it
yourself you can do that or as I would
you can set it and forget it and here's
why the value of wealthfront
is in the automation of habits and
strategies that investors should be
using on a regular basis but normally
aren't great investing is a marathon not
a sprint and little things that you may
or may not be familiar with like
automatic tax loss harvesting
rebalancing your portfolio across more
than ten asset classes and dividend
reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of
time wealthfront as I mentioned since
it's using software instead of retail
locations etc can offer all of this at
low costs that were previously
completely impossible right off the bat
you never pay commissions or account
fees for everything they charge 0.25
percent per year on assets above the
first fifteen thousand which is managed
for free if you use my link wealthfront
comm forward slash Tim that is less than
five dollars a month to invest a thirty
thousand dollar account for instance now
normally when I have a sponsor on this
show is because I use them and recommend
them in this case it's a little
different I don't use wealthfront yet
because I'm not allowed to here's the
deal they wanted to sponsor this podcast
but because of SEC regulations companies
that invest your money are not allowed
to use client testimonials so I couldn't
be a user and have them on the podcast
but I've been so impressed by
wealthfront that I've invested a
significant amount of my own money at
least for me in the team and the company
itself so I am an investor and hope to
soon use it as a client now back to the
recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show
listener you'll get fifteen thousand
dollars managed for free if you decide
to open an account but just start with
seeing the portfolio that they would
suggest for you take two minutes fill
out their questionnaire at wealthfront
comm forward slash Tim it's fast it's
free there's no downside that I can
think of